Kids that did well in school
did well in French, but nobody
really learned to speak French.
Hi there, Steve Kaufmann here,
and, and today I want to talk
about what I would do, how I would
teach language in a classroom.
Uh, remember if you enjoy these
videos, please subscribe, click
on the bell for notifications.
And, uh, if you follow me on
a podcast service, uh, you
know, please leave a comment.
I do appreciate it.
So I'm gonna talk about teaching
language, a language in a classroom,
which is something that I have
essentially never done, but I'm gonna
begin by telling two little stories.
Uh, first of all, I remember very clearly
that we had a teacher in high school who
was originally from the UK and this was in
Montreal and, uh, we were learning French.
He was the French teacher.
And I can remember that when we would
try to speak French in class, sometimes
he would preface that by saying "all
right, you guys, now we're gonna talk
frog language", which is maybe funny, and
people chuckled a bit but it really didn't
inspire much enthusiasm for what we were
about to attempt to do, speak French.
And then the second thing I remember was
when I was, uh, a student in France, I had
a job I used to go twice I think a week
I would go to a French family for lunch
and I was paid and I was given a small
amount and I was given a, a wonderful
meal, much better than the student
restaurant fair that I was used to.
And my job was to speak English
to the kids and the family.
There were, the parents were
there and they had two kids.
They all come home for
lunch and I was invited.
And so I'd finished my lunch
with, uh, a couple of glasses
of wine that they would give me.
And then I would bicycle halfway across
Paris to, uh, the Agricultural Institute.
... I don't know, actually
called whatever it was.
And I had to run in there and I
had to start this language lab.
So now we're talking about 1966/65.
Okay.
That's a long time ago.
And so here are all these aspiring,
you know, French farmers, I
guess, that we're studying at
the ... or whatever it's called.
And, uh, so, and they would be listening
to stuff on their, they had these tape
recorders, so it was a big language lab.
So there was like a big room.
There were people sitting at their
tape recorder, listening to this stuff.
I can't remember what my function was
other than to turn it on, or if people had
questions, but mostly they just sat there.
And one of the guys at the back of the
class, he took his big earphones off
he slammed them down on his desk and
he said ... in other words, I've been
studying French or English for 10 years,
and I still don't understand anything.
So that again, I remember that quite
vividly, becasue it, it made me laugh.
I remember that they had stuff in the
text that they were listening to terms
that I didn't even know in English like
stubble mulch, stubble mulch tillage.
I remember stubble mulch tillage.
So that's kind of my
experience with the classroom.
And I, I would say that in, um, in
high school or in elementary school,
the French was most uninteresting
and, uh, you know, kids that did well
in school did well in French, but
nobody really learned to speak French.
Uh, when I got to university I've
mentioned before I had this Dr.
Maurice Rabotan who was a great professor
who got me motivated to learn French
really inspired me to learn French.
And then my French took off.
So if I were a teacher, uh, if
I've envisioned the classroom.
So you can have a situation where
the teacher is a native speaker.
You can have a situation where the teacher
is not a native speaker but speaks the
language that he or she is teaching.
Well, you can have a situation where
the teacher doesn't speak that language
well, and you could even have a situation
where the teacher doesn't speak that
language at all today in the modern world
of the internet and MP3 and so forth.
And so I don't think it really matters
whether the teacher, uh, is fluent speaker
of the language or not better if he or
she is, I think better if he or she is a
native speaker, because I think that is,
is more inspirational for the learner that
they're learning the language from the
person who has that culture, that language
in them, but it's not a condition.
And there are so many opportunities
for the learner to hear the language,
first of all, obviously, to read
anything they wanna read in the
language and also to hear the language
via MP3 files, to discover content of
interest, even to connect with tutors
and rooms could be organized not like
that language lab, uh, situation in
France in 1965, but where you people
could have direct contact with tutors
in the language that they're learning.
So the teacher needn't provide that.
The language the teacher to my mind
is first and foremost is a motivator
like Maurice Rabotan motivated me
to learn French with tremendous
consequences because I went to
France, I became fluent in French.
I acquired that confidence
that I can learn languages.
So he had a tremendous impact on my life.
But a teacher, you know,
obviously because Mr.
Rabotan was French that was part of
what inspired me, but I think a very
good teacher, very encouraging teacher
can stimulate students and inspire them
and help them, even if the language
that the student is trying to learn is
not the native language of the teacher.
I think we need to look
at the language classroom.
Like if, if it were me, I would
encourage, I would encourage my students
to listen and read, obviously, uh, I
would encourage them to use uh, if I
were a teacher in a classroom, I could
have 25 kids and I could set aside, you
know, a range of content, 20 stories
that I know are suitable for them from
a number of different perspectives and
they can choose whichever one they want.
And I would be able to follow
how active they are, how much
they're reading, how much they're
listening, how many LingQs they're
creating, how much they're writing.
Uh, I could organize for them to talk
to look if I'm a native speaker, fine.
If I'm not, or if I'm not very fluent
in that language, I can arrange for them
twice a week to have online contacts
or maybe small group of them to have
online contacts with, uh, a teacher,
a native speaker from the country.
Uh, and they could talk about
things, uh, about the country or
about whatever the students are,
uh, reading and listening to.
And I wouldn't have to
create content all the time.
I wouldn't have to create lessons.
I wouldn't have to prepare like
a lot of teachers spend a lot
of time preparing their lessons.
Uh, I could follow exactly
what they're doing.
Also I wouldn't test them.
I would rely on keeping track of how
active they are because I, as I've said
before, many times, what matters is
how active are they with the language.
Some are gonna do better than others.
I don't want to discourage the ones
that are, you know, don't pronounce
as well or don't they don't seem to
do as well for whatever reason they
might start doing better later on.
So if they're struggling at an early
stage, why would I discourage them?
Rather I would want to control,
I'd wanna see how active they are
and if they're not very active,
how do I make them more active?
Is it because the content
is of no interest to them?
Uh, I'd have to try to find out
with each of these students, if
possible is not always possible.
How do I motivate them
to become more active?
The goal is to make them more active.
And so once you accept that the
teacher doesn't have to bring
the language to the student.
So the teacher doesn't have to be native.
Doesn't even have to be
proficient in the language.
It now opens up the possibility
that many more schools can offer
languages which they now don't
offer because they don't have an
accredited teacher in that language.
So you could offer five languages in
the classroom and encourage them to
go off and study, or even sit in the
classroom and listen and read right.
They're in the classroom.
Uh, if the classroom is only in
one language, of course we can have
conversations in the classroom and the
kids can talk about what they have been
reading and, uh, they can even talk
about words that they've been saving,
that they don't fully understand, and
other kids can comment on what they
think the word means and how it's used.
And we can have examples
of how that word is used.
If everyone is studying the
same language, it's much easier.
Uh, however, If in fact, some
people in that classroom, you
know, don't wanna study French.
And I've said before in Canada, you
know, it's like your civic obligation
to, to patriotic obligation.
If you're an English speaker, you
gotta learn French, but maybe the
kid doesn't wanna learn French, but
maybe he wants to learn Spanish or
he wants to learn Chinese or Russian.
So then if we can set it up so that
maybe out of 25 kids 15 are gonna do
French, but another 10 are gonna study
other languages of interest to them.
And we set it up so that they can do that.
And then of course, we have to
come up with activities in the
classroom, which at the very least
can be listening and reading.
The difficulty is if there's so
many different languages, then
some of these activities would
have to be again, solitary.
Uh, such as this, um, putting the
sentences back together again,
that I'm now doing in beta, uh,
at LingQ and we might devise
other activities for the kids.
Obviously it's easier if everyone is
studying the same language, not ideal,
if you have, uh, different languages,
but then we have to compare that to
the alternative, which is to sort
of force people to learn a language
that they're not interested in.
Uh, because motivation is such a, an
important part of language learning
that it was the case with me.
I think it's the case with most learners.
And we see the example in the Canadian
English language, school system
where unmotivated kids learning
French in fact, don't learn French.
So I think we have to strike a balance.
So it may not be, be ideal, but again,
I'll be the first to admit that these
ideas may not be practical, but, um,
I throw those out there as ideas.
If we look at where language
instruction was in the sixties, when
I was learning French at school, or
even when I was, or in the fifties,
I was learning French at school.
Or in the sixties when I was with these,
uh, students learning, you know, at
the , as you recall, in, in France, so
many things have changed the internet
MP3 technology and a whole bunch of
other, uh, technologies and resources,
language, resources, and so forth.
So maybe the way languages are taught
in schools will continue to evolve.
And perhaps some of the ideas that
I've mentioned here may have some
relevance, uh, for the classroom.
And I will leave you with, uh, two
older videos where I talk about the
classroom and individual learning uh,
and you'll see that, uh, maybe some
of my ideas have evolved over time.
So thank you very much for listening.
Bye for now.